- You know my next guests
as the very funny doctors
from the hit series Scrubs.
Now they have a podcast called
Fake Doctors, Real Friends
where they break down the good, the bad
and the hilariously embarrassing moments
of every single Scrubs episode,
which we all wanna know about.
I'm talking about Zach
Braff and Donald Faison.
Hey what's up, y'all?
- What is good?
- Thank you so much for doing this show,
I really, really appreciate it.
I know it's an awkward thing,
we tried to make it look like my show,
and I love that--
(laughs)
- Is that not a real background?
Is that like a virtual background?
- No dude, this is my former living room
and it's gone and they literally
put a whole set up behind me.
- It looks so cool.
- Donald are you in a closet?
- I am in my closet.
This is where I escape reality.
I escape the wife, I escape the kids,
and this is also where we do the podcast.
- That's amazing, it is funny
in this like, pandemic time
to find especially like we
were in a cabin in Montana,
now I'm in LA but,
we were in a cabin in
Montana, it's so small
and there's like nowhere to go,
and like literally would
end up in a bathroom.
(laughs)
And I was like, this is weird.
This is weird,
- Yeah.
- That I'm in a bathroom
- And like,
we started recording the podcast
and Donald needed to find
a place that was like,
good for sound, and so he
started with his closet.
And then he realized
that his kids didn't want
to come in there, and his
wife would leave him alone.
And so now I think his whole family thinks
he makes the podcast like every day.
- (laughs) He's just in
there doing crosswords
- Absolutely.
- Absolutely, sometimes I doodle.
(all laugh)
- Oh my god.
(Zach and Donald laughing)
Anyways, I just wanna ask you though,
because y'all are actual,
like real friends.
And that's why I like your podcast,
like fake doctors you
played on the TV show,
but you're real friends.
Like has it been hard?
Like I know we're all
like with our family,
it's nice to have that family time.
But I miss friends, like
do y'all miss each other,
like hanging out?
- [Donald] Oh I miss him tremendously.
- So much.
- I miss him so much, man.
- That's what started, y'know,
we were gonna do this
podcast before quarantine,
and 'cause we were planning on doing it.
And then when quarantine happened,
it became a thing where,
Donald and I, we can't see each other.
So like twice a week when we record,
we have like an hour
and a half to just laugh
and tell stories and catch up.
And y'know we talk about the show,
we talk about episodes of the show,
that's sort of like the
structure of the show.
But then we go off on all these tangents,
and it's actually given
us a formal structure
to like check in twice a week,
and tell stories and like crack up.
And it's like therapy,
- Yeah.
- Because y'know we're all lonesome,
and we're just cracking up.
- Yeah no, I--
- Yeah it's great,
it's great to be able to
talk to your best friend
for an hour and a half away
from the kids in silence,
for y'know, twice a week.
It's wonderful.
- Okay but just speaking up for your wife,
know that she wants that hour
to talk to her girls, okay.
- Oh no I know, trust me I know.
She complains about it all the time,
she's like "you know
I wish I had a podcast
where I could just--"
- I tell her,
- [Kelly] I wish I had
a reason to walk out--
- By the way I told CaCee, who's y'know,
Jessica Simpson's her best friend.
I go "Why don't you do a
podcast with Jessica Simpson?
You can have your own time."
- And she's like
"I should do that"
- First of all,
How funny would that be?
- That'd be hilarious!
- I know, I know.
- Wait--
- And then y'all could like,
you could merge yours sometimes.
- Right. (laughs)
- It could all come together.
- Well okay so, frontline workers
are really saving us these days.
And this is something
I actually never knew,
y'all actually shot
that at a real hospital.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- I was thinking that
was a set the whole time.
- [Donald] No.
- No we took over
an enormous hospital,
and we couldn't believe it either.
And everything was built into it.
There was four floors,
well then there was the
basement, and the roof,
so technically six,
'cause we used all of it.
And all our dressing
rooms were on one floor.
All the production offices
were another floor.
And then we would film every
single corner of the place.
Even the sets like our apartment,
that weren't the hospital,
they built into the hospital.
Kind of like your set
that's built into your
living room you said.
So--
- That's what's happening.
- Yeah, so it was amazing.
We kinda had our own campus.
We lived in an abandoned hospital
for eight and a half years.
- Yeah, it was really weird though.
For the first couple of seasons y'know,
I guess the hospital had just
recently become abandoned,
and people would just
straggle in off the street.
- Yep.
- Asking for, y'know,
asking for medicine and stuff.
- You're dressed up like doctors!
- Yeah.
- No and we'd be like,
(laughs)
"Sorry this isn't
a real hospital."
And they'd look around and see everyone
in costume in scrubs, in
nurses' outfits and everything,
and be like "What are you talking about?"
(laughs)
- Oh my god.
- I need your assistance now!
- At the entrance they
had to put up a huge sign
like "This is not a working hospital.
Do not come here for emergency care."
- Yeah.
- Wow, and I would have
felt horrible about that.
Like, turning people away.
- Yeah we had to be like "A
couple of miles down that way."
- You're like "Trust me, you don't want me
to do anything." (laughs)
- [Donald] Oh, no--
- Okay so Donald, since
you've been isolated
from each other for a while,
what do you miss doing the most together?
- I miss dinners, y'know what I mean.
'Cause we get a chance to talk a lot.
I miss dinners and drinking wine together,
and y'know, laughing over a meal.
I miss that the most.
- Okay all of a sudden
I wanna be real friends
with you as well.
(laughs)
- Because--
- Will you come be real friends with us?
(laughs)
- You're more than welcome to.
- I mean that sounds awesome.
- Kelly really the only
reason Donald and I
wanted to come on your show,
other than to plug our podcast,
was to hope that maybe
you would be our friend
and come to dinner with
us when this is all over.
(Kelly laughs)
- You are welcome any time.
- I am like literally,
like I think we're all
so excited too about,
I mean dinner parties, or
going out to restaurants.
Anything like other than
what's been happening,
like I am down.
- I know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So Zach have you decided--
- It's so nice to see new faces.
You know when you--
- I know.
- When you get on a Zoom call,
even if it's like for,
I don't know if you guys feel this,
but when you get on a Zoom call,
even if it's for work or something,
and you see new people,
you're like,
- [Kelly] I know--
- "tell me about your living room."--
(Donald laughing)
- And then you start telling stories
that are really not good stories
but it's just what's happening,
- [Zach] Yeah.
- and they're y'know,
so entertained by them.
And I'm like why am I entertained by this,
it's another level of sad.
- And do you find yourself
looking at peoples' backgrounds,
Like, I'm like looking at like,
"Oh what book is that?"
(laughs)
"Oh that's a bold paint
color, I might try that."
- Oh she got a--
- That actually happened to me
when I was getting
interviewed by Seth Myers.
And I actually recognized
one of the books,
not realizing that he was
putting it up there to be funny,
that they're dumb books to him,
and I was like "Oh I've seen
that little miniseries."
And he was like "Oh, yeah."
And then I just pissed myself.
(laughs)
Like, okay.
What were you going to say, Donald?
- I was gonna say "Oh that's
a Gibson on the wall."
That was the first thing I recognized,
- Oh!
- I was like,
oh she got guitars on the wall!
Is one of them a Gibson?
- Yeah both of them are Gibsons.
- Oh, ooh. (laughs)
- Yes, yass.
I play guitar poorly, that's
the best part of my show,
that we have guitars on
walls, but I play poorly.